Table six now Lauren GQ essentials soft
sticks you're welcome
what's up GQ it's Niall Horan here and
these are my essentials
I like navy blue
can you guess he did thanks for sorry
about the length of this this Dyson
hairdryer best thing that ever happened
I've got quite crazy hair so I needed
something that helps me control the
madness any sort of humidity I would
never be able to live in New York City
for instance so this thing is vital this
goes everywhere with me
I even have one for America one for the
UK so I don't have to switch around with
y'all adapters and the power and stuff
this Dyson one my barber in the UK Larry
thought he used all of these in his
salon and he gave me this one so I can
bring it all over the world and make
sure that it looks half decent that is
essential number one for sure
essential number two Sarah Chapman
facemask paper mask Sarah Chapman is a
lady who works in London mostly skin in
skin care linen paper masks get a bit
moisture in there do a lot of traveling
spend a lot of time on planes so the
skin dries out a little bit you know it
got to be on camera all the time and
these things are a must for moisturizing
your skin in the evening and based on my
first two I sound really vain I'm just
plenty more where I came from
on the topic of moisturizing Hydra
flasks these have become a bit of a
thing recently it's basically an
extension of my arm I like to drink a
lot of water I don't really drink soft
drinks generally and I bring these
everywhere mainly because recently I've
gotten into trying to help in whatever
way I can save the planet
I'm know like eco-warrior but I feel
like this is my start so these are a
must drink water save the planet and
they look half decent essential number
four the guitar Thank You square this is
my personal guitar
that happens to be in tune even though I
didn't do that I roll basically my last
two albums on this thing I played on
stage every night on my Flickr world
tour last year it's by an Irish brand
called Loudon and they hand make all the
guitars they don't sell that many
guitars a year based on how much pride
they put into the woods that they choose
and I got to sit down with them and kind
of make this edge here and use them
sometimes if I'm just watching TV I'll
be I'd be just kind of practicing and
just kind of sitting there just kind of
fiddling around with it and if there was
no guitars and my house it would be a
very boring house so I'm glad that I was
able to take up this instrument as a kid
and it makes some sweet tones essential
but like me the guitar
next item sunglasses
it's a most any type of sunglasses these
ones are faults mate but generally it
can I wear whatever I like wearing
sunglasses a lot obviously because it's
sunny I've got sensitive IDs I'm wearing
them indoors right now and I don't
really know why you bought one camera so
I might as well I just like wearing
sunglasses I like trying out different
ones different shapes see if they suit
me obviously they're good for when
you're out and about and I can wear a
hat and glasses and just kind of keep
the head down you probably won't even
recognize me now would you
also one thing I do have in my favor is
that I don't have the blonde hair
anymore so people actually still think I
have blonde hair even though I haven't
had blonde hair for five years so people
always know of me as a little blonde
fellow with the Irish accent things have
changed around here
another essential baseball cap not gonna
put it on now because I just did my hair
in America people get very touchy about
what team it is can't wear that head
around here son a lot of kind of stuff
but I can don't know many American
sports or teams so this is obviously one
of the most famous logos in the world
and we're in New York so I do tend to
wear this one a lot they're really good
for when I need to keep my head down
again it's like sunglasses I could
probably walk around Times Square in
that and I probably will we've got a
billboard there right now and I want to
go and see it amongst all the other
tourists to came to New York and bought
a New York he's at baseball cap always
essentially their main essential golf
clubs anyone that knows me whether you
know me or not you know one thing about
me I play golf and golf clubs are a big
one for me I always bring them
everywhere everywhere I go people don't
know if I'm a musician or a goal for
these days because I walk out of
airports with golf clubs I have a golf
management company where I manage young
European golfers with a minute and yeah
they're good friends with the guys at
Taylor Made and they make up my clubs
for me fit moat for me some of my
favorite golf courses I've played st.
Andrews the home of golf in Scotland
royal Portrush where the Open
Championship was this year I was also
very very fortunate to be invited
Augusta National the home of the Masters
Tournament for many years money can't
buy your way in there you have to be
invited in as you can see from
television it's pretty spectacular my
favorite place in the world are none I
don't want to go on about all the great
course template but I've been looking
enough to play in some pretty cool golf
course and if you're a gulfs nerd like
me you can appreciate what I've just
said for the last 30 seconds
another essential a very important one
this is a Paul Smith suit I'm good
friends with Paul Smith himself great
man this particular suit is one that I
brought especially for today because I
wore this suit to the American Music
Awards a few years ago when I won Best
New Artist still probably my favorite
tune that I've ever worn it's got like a
little tartan kind of check number going
on and what I love about Paul Smith is
he always puts all these crazy colors on
the inside of the jacket and like even
back the pocket is a different color he
always does something really cool with
his suits and I'm lucky enough to know
the guy and now when I look inside the
inside of his jacket I understand
because his personality matches exactly
what he's tailored every suit that I put
on has to be Paula Smith and if it's not
Paula Smith I feel like I'm cheating on
the guy next date of a hand steamer I
think I got this one on tour last year
probably in Walmart or something like
that on the road I'm not very good at
ironing so I basically got this thing
cause it's so handy just get it up turn
on steam comes out up and down Get
Alerts theme go on get all the creases
Oh I mean I've used it this morning
there's still water in the bottom of it
gets your clothes looking more decent
than they did when they were just pulled
out of a suitcase so hand steamer is a
must
[Music]
last essential Larry King's velvet
texture clay Larry King is my barber in
London and he actually caught my hair
this morning he happened to be in New
York and cut my hair that's what he
looks alright this the office of his new
product line that he just brought out
recently it's like really easy to use
you don't need a lot you just let the P
size as they always say just give it a
good rub get it in there and just get
free see it's kind of like movable are
there you don't have to worry about
whatever going like get putting in too
much and it looking really greasy when
I'm moving all the time and there's
different things to go to and blah blah
I can just put a little bit and give it
a rub around this look like this when I
do it but definitely looks like this
when he does it I've been Niall Horan
I'll always been that Lauren GQ thank
you so much they were my essentials I
hope I didn't bore you to death and I
hope you get something out of it thank
you